There are 115 more videos to watch. In fact,
there are 117 more videos to watch
was that different.
Helium is the second element on the periodic table. It makes up
35% of our universe,
but it's very rare here on the planet earth. In fact,
it's the only element in the periodic table that was first
discovered outside of planet.
The first indications of its existence came when people were
looking at the spectrum of the sun in,
during the eclipse in 1868,
the year before Mandalay have proposed the periodic table and they noticed a
single very bright yellow line.
The yellow line is due to the electrons, helium,
atom, being excited. You can do the same thing here on earth. In fact,
Neil has his own helium star.
This is a glass star filled with helium gas.
And if you apply very high voltage,
you can excite the electrons in the helium and it emits light.
And then with a small spectroscope,
you can look at it and see the very yellow line that was detected in the sun
spectrum to begin with. They thought it was sodium,
but then they realized it must be a new element.
And because it was found on the sun,
it was given the name helium from the Greek word Helios,
which is,
I believe what the sun is called in Greek or the God of the sun is called.
It was then discovered on earth.
At the beginning of the 20th century with people were examining a
uranium mineral called I think CLI Vite.
Then a few years later,
fairly rapidly helium gas was discovered as a
component of natural gas coming out of gas fields in the
United States.
The reason why you find helium associated with uranium,
and in fact,
other radioactive materials is because the
nucleus of helium contains two neutrons and two
protons.
And the naked nucleus of helium is water called alpha
particles that are emitted during radioactive decay.
So if a radioactive atom,
decays and emits an alpha particle underground,
the alpha particle quickly picks up a couple of electrons and
becomes an item of helium. And over millions of years,
this can accumulate in gas field. As far as I'm aware,
all of the helium in the world has come from radioactive decay
apart from a small amount that has come from people letting of
hydrogen bomb.
The width of the fireball at this time,
about three seconds after that nation was four miles.
Helium in the natural gas was discovered fairly shortly
before the first world war.
And so it was quickly realized that this gas could be useful
for observation balloons on the Western front, on the battlefields.
The enemy troop movements and defense schemes are under constant observation by
French and British airman, as well as by observation balloons.
Because unlike hydrogen, it doesn't burn.
So if a bullet goes through your balloon, it doesn't immediately blow up.
So helium started to be produced as a strategic material.
Non-expensive gas for the originals and Medica has a virtual monopoly of it
healing.
So there's a long history in the United States of legislation for conserving
helium for strategic defense purposes.
It has of course attracted great attention all over the world because of the
terrible Hindenburg disaster.
The American president's cabinet committee is convinced that helium should not
be made available to Germany, but you will send commercial ashes.
So helium,
nucleus or helium atom weighs four times as much as a
hydrogen atom, which has just one proton,
but because hydrogen exists as an H two molecule
helium atom,
which is the same as its molecule weighs twice as much as a hydrogen
molecule and Neil,
our colleague has divided quite a nice little demonstration.
So.
Well, yeah,
he has a balloon of hydrogen and the balloon of helium of about
the same size and shows that the hydrogen balloon
with a suitable police system can actually pull the helium
balloon downwards because it there's a lot more lift in a
hydrogen balloon than in the helium one, because the hydrogen is lighter.
The most important property for helium nowadays is the fact
that when you liquefy it,
it forms the coldest liquid that one can
obtain
liquid helium boils at minus 269
degrees centigrade.
That is four degrees above absolute zero.
So you can use liquid helium to cool materials
down.
And particularly you can cool certain alloys of
metals,
which lose all their electrical resistance at low temperature so-called
superconductors,
which can be used to build really powerful magnets,
particularly for our university for magnetic resonance imaging
for looking inside people's bodies to see that all is well,
and you need a very high magnetic field.
And so our university has a plant for
liquefying helium and Brady,
and I were able to go and visit it.
We were shown how the liquid helium is filled into
large thermos flowers. So-called Dewar flasks.
When you want to prompt the helium out remarkably,
you use the inside of a rugby football.
This is the bladder inside it.
A rugby football is quite similar to an American football and you,
by squeezing this, you can pressurize the helium and get it to come out.
And if you do it wrong, it blows up to a large size the bladder.
And we were shown what's happened. I was a bit frightened. It might impact.
We were then shown what happens when you squirt liquid helium into air.
And it's really strange because as the liquid comes out,
the jet of liquid looks very like a flavor.
The shape is almost the same though. Of course, it's whitish in color.
Neil had given us a small metal stainless steel thermals
can, it's very important.
It's stainless steel because helium can go through
gloves. So if you use a glass thermals, as soon as you put helium into it,
it stops being a thermos vessel.
Neil wanted just to try and see if we could fill this kind with liquid helium.
So we could actually show you what the liquid looked like.
[Inaudible].
We had the number of attempts and the most spectacular
eruptions of cold helium vapor.
The problem is that helium vapor that comes off is so cold,
not totally freezes on the water vapor in the air. So you get the fog,
but it can also liquefy the oxygen or nitrogen in the
air.
So even though we pre-cool the Thermo's with liquid
nitrogen, so we started at a fairly low temperature.
It was quite difficult to get the liquid in.
And once we got it in,
there was so much folk that it was quite difficult to tell whether we were
really seeing the surface of the liquid or not, but it was great fun,
Breeds, DNA really enjoyed ourselves.
And the technician Sanjeev was really helpful.
He even tried filling a much bigger vessel with Nick
and pouring it into our thermals.
Yes.
When people use liquid helium, seriously, for example,
for magnetic resonance imaging,
because the gas is expensive,
it is piped back to the liquefaction plant.
So it can be recycled.
And you've all seen little helium balloons that people use at parties and the
Lake, but at the liquefaction plant,
they have an enormous yellow balloon,
which they use for storing the gas before it's liquified.
And they have gas meters to measure the volume of gas coming back so
that they knew how much gas has been lost and how much they have to
charge each customer for the guests that they've lost.
I used to work with liquid Tealium long time ago,
and I still have the very old gas meter that we used,
which is just over there on the filing cabinet.
Thanks for watching this video.
We actually filmed a lot more stuff about helium that we haven't fit into this
one, but we're going to upload another helium video very soon.
So you can see all that stuff.
You can also watch our videos about all the different elements we've done all
118. Some of them numerous times,
there's a link to a playlist of those videos. Also,
we've obviously done hundreds of other chemistry videos.
And if you'd like to support us,
you can go to patrion.com/periodic videos and find out more
there, including our little gimmick, where you can adopt an element,
including helium.